hey yo what up [ __ ] sorry wrong
channel now for Gomer
my name's Bonnie Barbera and welcome to
don't come near me
you're coming near me you're eating man
so for this week's fry I want to do a
Q&A because it's been a while so I
suppose on Twitter to ask me anything
left boy say em without your lips
touching I don't know what you brothers
think a question is but usually I'll end
with a question mark and it's a [ __ ]
question
say I'm without your lips touch hmm am i
a pretty girl
yes which superpower would you pick this
is an opportunity I could pick anything
I think out of all things I would like
to not wipe my butt when I take a poop
when you meet the Queen of England she
said she wants you to sit on her face
but it's a secret okay what I feel like
half you bros are on drugs I'm sorry
what the [ __ ] what does the Fox say
actually the Fox can a sound like a bird
dying from diarrhea the Mauryan not with
us when did you find out that you're a
duck can you make Maya and gonna have a
cough okay
see what I can do about that one I'm
sure your [ __ ] are flawless
how does a unicorn poop how the hell
would I even know that it's not like I'm
a unicorn how do i style my hair Thank
You Mars alright that it if that's
actually a secret but if you come a
little closer I'll tell it to come click
come closer come okay there we go
yeah alright alright you ready you ready
you [ __ ] cat what animals are cute to
you I don't really think any animals at
all are cute I think they're all kind of
ugly
uh what socks are you wearing right now
if you were a girl why would your name
be
Bedelia write a poem that's not a
question but since you asked nicely
actually you didn't do you ever had fart
battles with Matt yeah tadhana hold on
hold on are you supposed to have fought
battles with your girlfriend I've been
missing out holy [ __ ] mater are you
planning to start on your series soon
yes I'm super I don't know when it's
coming out but I'm super pumped for The
Walking Dead Season 2 game coming out if
you were gay for would you date I don't
I don't know
and that's sorry I'm not gay I don't
know I don't have anyone except maybe
while weights more a ton of bricks or a
ton of feathers hmm I guess there's a
lot of things consider with your mom's
but what makes you happy in life
well I really enjoy making these videos
ah my girlfriend a dog's my family wait
next time you fart say do I smell
popcorn that way everybody takes a deep
breath to smell popcorn but it's really
your fart genius what do you think about
a new youtube comment section at the
moment at the moment it's very broken
and I think everyone loves to point out
that it is but I think eventually
they'll left they'll figure it out and
hopefully you can actually read comments
that'd be great
can you put impersonate Miley Cyrus
without twerking sure sure I can a Miley
Cyrus ah okay I can't I can't do it okay
what do you what where do you see
yourself in five years
and the future is that we fired how do
you pronounce your last name it's sad if
I talked America and I say shell burg
but if I'm Swedish I'd say shell body
actually not like that at all but still
you can try it if you want to that's all
the time I had for the question today
hope you boys enjoyed watching every
time you labor like you saved the life
of a duck guy wasn't true they died
anyway they must all die I wanted to
make a quick announcement I'm gonna be
playing games with you bros I wanted to
do free to play games because it's
anyone can play it literally so if you
want to play games from me I left a link
in the description we're gonna play some
smite all the all the info about this is
in the description I think it'll be
pretty cool I miss just doing these
things with you bro so I'm looking
forward to it
other than that I hope girls have a
great weekend get fat and don't move
actually that's a terrible idea exercise
and feel great
yeah or you can just stay home and watch
all my videos thanks again for all the
support bros you're the best I think you
know it by now
but here's the breakfast to prove it
stay awesome bros love you know timbered
house my house my family what in the
name of Jon Bon Jovi's going on